l' enquête sur l'attentât de la rue
copernic n'a donc pas beaucoup progressé
aujourd'hui à partir de la moto
retrouvée déchiquetée devant la
synagogue les policiers sont remontés
jusqu'au magasin où la moto a été vendue
et à partir du magasin ils ont retrouvé
l'hôtel où a séjourné le propriétaire de
cette fameuse moto si vous voulez les
policiers ont reconstitué l'itinéraire
de cet homme c'est tout les policiers
n'en savent pas plus ou bien ils ne
veulent pas en dire plus pour le moment
le poids avec françois jacquel
reconstituer l'emploi du temps et
l'itinéraire de l'homme à la moto voilà
qui permettrait en effet aux enquêteurs
de découvrir son identité et pourtant
rien ne prouve encore que c'est dans ce
magasin de l'avenue de la grande armée
que l'homme en question est acheté sa
moto pour mille dollars sais tu vu qui
125 retrouvés rue copernic sans que son
propriétaire les réclamer c'est
néanmoins à partir des indications
fournies par le vendeur que les
policiers ont pu retrouver l'adresse de
l'hôtel où l'homme a séjourné ne tel de
la rue balzac à quelques pas des champs
elysées la direction confirme avoir reçu
des enquêteurs mais refuse de fournir la
moindre précision sur l'identité de son
client d'un jour rien ne prouve non plus
qu'il n'y aucune trace de ce client qui
comme tout autre a dû remplir une fiche
à son arrivée et présenter un passeport
un passeport au nom de alexander fana
rue de nationalité chypriote rien ne
prouve que ce soit la véritable identité
du tueur c'est ce qu'a répondu
l'ambassade de chypre lorsque les
policiers sont venus préciser que
l'homme à la moto parler un bon français
avec un accent du moyen-orient en résumé
et pour l'instant aucune preuve nous a
été communiquée permettant d'interpréter
ou de connaître la véritable signature
de cet attentat